المزيد عن تفاصيل هذا المشهد ينضم الينا
من مقر المحيط لمقر البنك المركزي في
بيروت مراسل الجزيره
جونيوس واجواء هذا الاعتصام
في الواقع عبد الصمد منذ نحو ساعه من الان
يتجمع هؤلاء المحتجون امام مقر المصرف
المركزيه اللبناني هنا في شارع الحمراء
واغلب الحاضرين هنا هم من العسكريين
المتقاعدين كان هذا التحرك بدا في محيط
مقر الحكومه في ساحه رياض الصلح في وسط
بيروت وانتقل المحتجون سيرا على الاقدام
الى هذه المنطقه وطبعا العنوان الرئيسي
الاعتراض على السياسات الماليه التي تعتمد
في البلاد وينفذها ويطبقها المصرف المركزي
ويشارك في وضعها بطبيعه الحال وايضا يطالب
هؤلاء بتحسين رواتبهم التقاعديه التي فقدت
جزءا كبيرا من قيمتها نتيجه تراجع قيمه
الليره اللبنانيه في الاعوام الثلاثه
الماضيه
مقارنه بالدولار الامريكي
بعد هؤلاء المحتاجين كانوا اقتربوا الى
المدخل الاساسي للمصرف المركزي ولكن هناك
اجراءات امنيه مشدده منعتهم من الاقتراب
يمكننا ان نرصد او ربما رصدتم قبل بعض
الوقت عدد منهم قاموا بتسلق الجدران التي
تحيط بمقر المصرف المركزي والتي وضعت مع
بدايه الازمه في لبنان قاموا بقطع بعض
الاسلاك الشائكه وهناك الان نوع من
التدافع بين القوى الامنيه الحاضره هنا في
محيط المصرف المركزي المولجه بحمايه مقر
المصرف المركزي وبين المحتجين علما ان
هؤلاء وذكرت ان اغلبهم هم من العسكريين
المتقاعدين اكدوا مرارا رفضهم الاحتكاك مع
عناصر السلك العسكري الموجودين في الخدمه
حاليا ولكن واضح من خلال ما نرصده حاله
الهرج والمرج ليس هذا الاعتصام الاول من
نوعه الاسبوع الماضي القت القوى الامنيه
قنابل دخ في محيط السرايا الحكوميه من اجل
ابعاد المحتجين وكان اغلبهم ايضا من
العسكريين المتقاعدين هذه المشاهد وهذه
التحركات تحصل على وقع اشتداد وضعت الازمه
الاقتصاديه ويقول هؤلاء المحتجون ايضا ان
اعتماد المصرف المركزي سعر منصه سيرفصه
التي انشاها للتعاملات التجاريه عند عتبه
90 الف ليره لبنانيه لكل دولار ليزيد من
وضع الازمه عليهم ويفقدهم نصف رواتبهم
التقاعديه مقارنه بالشهر الماضي وايضا
هؤلاء طبعا يطالبون بتحسين التقديمات
المتعلقه ببدلات الطبابه والتنقل والتعليم
هنا لابد من الاشاره طبعا الى ان الليره
اللبنانيه فقدت اكثر من
95% من قيمتها منذ بدا الازمه طبعا حاله
من التدافع
بين الامنيه
والمحتجين
تحاول القوى الامنيه وتحديدا العناصر
العسكريه ابعاد المحتجين من محيط السرايا
من محيط المصرف المركزي عفوا
منعا لحصول اي احتكاكات اضافيه علما انه
كما كنت ذكرت حجم الطوق الامنيه الذي يحيط
بالمصرف المركزي طوق امني كبير